[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi votre rêve alors là je vais
vous inviter à pendant que je vous parle
à peut-être penser ou alors visualiser
votre rêve n'importe lequel
puis là je vais vous inviter à vivre une
rapide expérience et pour cela je vais
vous le souhaitez à fermer les yeux
et je vous inviter à vivre ou à
visualiser votre rêve
entre nous
puis maintenant inviter à venir sentir
observer si vous sentez quelque chose
dans votre corps
peut-être même une ou des émotions
ok toujours les yeux fermés je vais vous
inviter à prendre une grande inspire
et à vous dire c'est possible
et oui pourquoi pas
je vous invite à reprendre une grande
inspire une grande expire
et ouvrir les yeux quand c'est ok pour
vous
puis maintenant alors vous poser
quelques petites questions vous pouvez
lever la main pour y répondre
qui a eu une ou deux images
ok qui a eu une ou plusieurs sensations
sont encore
des émotions
ok peut-être les trois à la fois
OK
maintenant une autre question
prononce les mots sportifs de haut
niveau
pareil vous pouvez lever la main un
basketteur
un footballeur
une danseuse
un skieur
une tenniswoman OK
en effet tout est juste tout le monde a
raison
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous parler de
quelque chose donc du cerveau chez le
sportif mais également du système
nerveux autonome c'est un système que
nous possédons tous
le système nerveux autonome comme son
nom l'indique il est autonome c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas le contrôler
et puis voilà dans le système nerveux
autonome quand même il lui va certaine
fonction autonome de notre corps comme
la récupération
la digestion la respiration le sommeil
les tensions musculaires etc mais aussi
la motivation ou le découragement ou le
manque de volonté
il est aussi en train du
contexte émotionnel dans lequel nous
évoluons donc là pour moi c'est une clé
incroyable pour les sportifs c'est à
dire qu'en connaissant leur état de
système nerveux autonome ils peuvent
l'adapter à leur capacités sportives
un basketteur quand il a un moment
d'hésitation son cerveau lui dit oh
attends un peu
cette seconde ou demi seconde hésitation
en fait c'est avoir ça va avoir une
répercussion sur l'action et le jeu
OK
pareil quand on vous dit aussi là on
vous dit tu es nul
tu n'y arriveras pas
deux choses soit il y a une motivation
un truc un peu qui s'agite Qui a envie
d'être productif à l'intérieur de vous
ou alors peut-être que ça va même vous
mettre au défi
et puis là j'ai envie de m'appuyer sur
la théorie polyvagale alors attendez
parce que du coup
la théorie polyvagate du docteur
Stéphane portgiès lui il met en lumière
trois états du système nerveux trois
branches
donc le ventral le sympathique et le
dorsal j'ai tout de suite envie de vous
donner des exemples très concrets le
ventral c'est quoi c'est quand je suis
bien quand je me sens profondément bien
et en sécurité par exemple quand vous
êtes dans les bras de votre compagnon de
votre compagne que vous vous sentez bien
le sympathique c'est quand je fais tout
pour y arriver que je mets tout en œuvre
pour y arriver mais que je n'y arrive
pas parce que je stresse j'ai tout de
suite envie de faire le lien avec la
motivation
la motivation elle va donc naître soit
dans le ventral soit dans le sympathique
pour moi quand on connaît plus on va
connaître les États du système nerveux
autonome et le sportif plus va connaître
dans quel état il va se situer plus ça
va l'aider à le placer dans ses
capacités sportives
donc tout cela ça s'entraîne et c'est un
super outil parce que ça va permettre
aux sportifs de réguler ou d'adapter ses
gestes sa manière de faire peut-être
même avoir le geste juste
donc là on peut aussi imaginer qu'il y a
une zone où on est productif
cette zone c'est le flot le flot c'est
quoi c'est donner le meilleur de moi
sans même y penser et mon corps il suit
c'est cette fluidité que le sportif peut
connaître et d'ailleurs quand on quand
on interview en sportif après qu'il est
réalisé une compétition très souvent il
dit je sais pas ça c'est hyper bien
passé c'était hyper fluide naturel
alors moi l'entraînement physique oui
j'y crois mais à mon sens un
entraînement mental aussi l'entraînement
de savoir dans quel état on est dans le
système nerveux va aussi vraiment être
intéressant pour le sportif
autre données importante à mon sens et
que le vécu programme le système nerveux
autonome
c'est dans le système nerveux autonome
que l'on trouve la motivation la
détermination mais on peut possiblement
y trouver les invalidations de la
motivation et la détermination en somme
plus le sportif connais ses états plus
va pouvoir les décoder va venir sentir
et écouter ses émotions plus ça va lui
être bénéfique
une fois qu'on pose tout cela il y a une
notion très importante pour moi qui est
comment prendre soin du cerveau du
sportif il y a deux pistes à mon sens
qui sont pistes traumatiques alors c'est
quelque chose que tous les sportifs
peuvent connaître c'est-à-dire la
blessure ça peut être aussi être relégué
sur le banc de touche enchaîner
plusieurs défaites successives peut-être
même un mauvais relationnel avec son
coach ou avec quelqu'un de son équipe
et la deuxième piste c'est l'aspect
motivationnel c'est-à-dire
déjà j'ai envie de dire que le la piste
traumatique elle s'accompagne donc ça se
prend en charge tout au long de
l'accompagnement du sportif puis la
seconde piste c'est la piste
motivationnelle qui elle s'entraîne plus
au long cours alors c'est super des
débriefés d'un match ou d'une
compétition sur un point de vue TIC
tactique technique physique c'est super
mais à mon sens ça pourrait être aussi
intéressant de proposer
un débrief sur l'aspect émotionnel
comment et où on fait dans le système
nerveux sportif moi l'expérience que
j'ai c'est que très souvent ils savent
où ils se situent juste c'est pas mal de
leur poser la question
c'est quand on est dans ces deux aspects
de du système VO autonome qu'à mon sens
le sportif peut être dans la réussite
autre chose le cerveau il joue un joli
rôle d'arbitre c'est à dire que fort du
vécu de la personne il va toujours bah
voilà il va choisir il va il va il va
arbitrer en donnant soit des Go soit des
non Go le go on peut imaginer on peut
même le dire que c'est dans le ventre
si tu es dans le ventral et le cerveau
va être vas-y c'est bon tu peux y aller
et le logo que le cerveau peut donner
c'est d'être par exemple dans
car c'est pas par exemple c'est que
l'aide endorsale et que soit il va par
exemple être dans l'évitement ou alors
il va être dans le je fais je fonce mais
je fonce tellement que j'y arrive pas ça
folle et puis d'ailleurs c'est souvent
là que la blessure intervient
vous allez me dire mais comment on sort
de ces états du lait ou alors comment on
régule le système nerveux autonome
déjà on peut pas passer du dorsal au
sympathique comme ça c'est à dire que le
système nerveux a besoin de passer un
step premier step c'est du dorsal au
sympathique comment faire très
concrètement c'est déjà sorti de
l'insécurité du danger de pas être bien
pour remonter dans quelque chose d'un
peu plus actif donc on peut passer par
le corps il peut bouger faire des
mouvements
respirer voilà ce ne sont que quelques
exemples
et après pour passer du sympathique
et bien ça va être mettre du lien
regardez quelqu'un plus intensément
peut-être recevoir des encouragements de
la part de son coach peut-être faire une
accolade avec son son coéquipier en tout
cas c'est de remettre du lien émotionnel
et c'est là qui va pouvoir être ventrale
et derrière être plus serein pour
adapter ses gestes ces gestes justes etc
j'ai quand même envie de donner deux
autres exemples qui peuvent nous parler
à tous sur cet aspect dorsale un peu de
panique par exemple imaginez-vous vous
êtes arrivés ici au Teddie que si vous
n'aviez pas votre billet ça panique ou
alors le truc qu'on connaît peut-être un
peu plus c'est j'ai perdu mes clés je
les cherche un peu frénétiquement dans
mon sac jusqu'au moment où j'en ai marre
j'ouvre mon sac je le vide et je les
retrouve
ça nous arrive souvent ça peut arriver
donc ça c'est voilà c'est un exemple
l'autre exemple chez les sportifs c'est
pareil c'est peut-être un coach qui va
vous donner une vous dire quelque chose
qui va pas être ok qui va vous toucher
émotionnellement réflexion peut-être que
je vais avoir envie que la terre s'ouvre
sous mes pieds que je me glisse dedans
peut-être avec un sentiment de honte
déjà ça c'est aussi contre-productif et
ça va venir me toucher émotionnellement
donc me mettre en dorsale et limiter
l'action se sentir pas productif voir
être démotivé
vous allez me dire mais Salia
on n'est pas tout le temps dans ces
états quand même et ben en fait si le
cerveau et le système nerveux c'est le
garant de votre survie c'est lui qui
assure les fonctions autonomes et qui
donne des goss et des nongos sur ce que
vous faites hésitation action je suis
bien ou pas
donc en fait il passe son temps à faire
ça d'ailleurs peut-être que dans votre
vie à chacun là vous pouvez retrouver un
moment ou un exemple de je suis pas bien
eu entendu quelques et ça va vous
atteindre vous mettre un peu en panique
un danseur quand il va aller en
compétition il va avoir une tenue
spécifique des chaussures spécifiques un
éclairage qui va être différent va aller
bouillir d'une manière différente
peut-être que la scène va être inconnue
et peut-être même le sol c'est pas celui
sur lequel il a l'habitude de performer
tout ça le cerveau le premier se dit ouh
là là mais c'est quoi ces nouvelles
données
et alors soit il connaît ses états de
système nerveux autonome et il s'est
régulé il a eu les outils on lui a donné
les outils pour réguler ou alors il
panique appréhension et puis sa
performance voire même sa motivation
peut-être entamée
de même un joueur de foot il y a pas que
lui et le ballon sur le terrain il y a
lui le ballon c'est dit coéquipiers
c'est 11 adversaires les arbitres le
coach sur la ligne de touche qui va
peut-être crier des choses voilà des
indications il y a peut-être les
supporters qui supportent ou alors
et là le sportif le joueur foot peut se
dire ok là il y a un truc qui se passe
les supporters Yu ou alors oulala on a
raté un but et ça forcément ça va
générer un impact émotionnel
donc tout cela dit il y a une zone dans
le cerveau qui appelle le système
réticulé activateur tout ça dans notre
tête dans notre cerveau qui va alors lui
il fait quoi son but c'est de
sélectionner l'information sur des
critères émotionnels
donc le vécu de la personne tout ce
qu'elle a vécu voilà ça va influer donc
les émotions voilà les émotions aussi
c'est un peu notre Google interne
imaginez-vous vous dire à l'intérieur de
vous ok Google interne dis-moi ce que je
dois faire
j'y vais j'y vais pas Jésus j'hésite pas
je plaisante mais on n'est pas si loin
que ça de la réalité le cerveau du coup
fort du vécu il a une bonne grosse
banque de données et il va choisir il va
vous dire ok vas-y ok ça c'est à peu
près bon ou alors n'y va pas
ce Google interne moi j'aime bien
l'appeler GPS c'est le GPS de notre être
plus le sportif à connaître entendre
décoder ce GPS intérieur plus il va
adapter ses actions son hésitation ou
pas et ça ça va venir être au service du
sportif du collectif mais aussi des
objectifs
alors là j'ai envie de prendre un
exemple j'adore le foot
au-delà d'accompagner des footballeurs
j'adore le foot et il y a un truc que je
regarde en ce moment c'est les matchs du
PSG et en fait j'ai remarqué un truc
c'est que Neymar mais si Mbappé c'est un
truc de fou parce que ils arrivent à
mener des actions dans un mouchoir de
poche
et je me dis quand même soit il se
connaissent vachement bien et il connaît
vachement bien leur système nerveux et
quelqu'un leur enseigne pas ce qui est
possible ou alors en fait c'est qu'ils
sont tellement dans leur ventrale ils
sont tellement bien quand ils sont dans
une action et aussi ils arrivent à
décoder cela chez leur copains leurs
collègues que du coup ça donne une
action formidable je sais pas si vous
suivez mais il marque quand même pas mal
en ce moment
et du coup moi je me dis quand même
c'est qu'ils sont aussi en sécurité les
uns avec les autres et qu'ils y arrivent
et que ça fonctionne
ok une fois que j'ai dit cela
moi ce que je fais avec les sportifs
quand je passe par la visualisation le
cerveau il va garder un marqueur plus
fort quand il est associé à une émotion
forte
donc le système réticulé activateur
c'est aussi son rôle si on associe un
moment avec une émotion le cerveau va le
garder plus en mémoire il va chercher à
le refaire avec le corps
bon ok du coup moi ce que je fais
souvent c'est que je leur fais prendre
une situation vécue un vrai moment vécu
je leur fais retrouver l'émotion
associée je lis le tout et on va le
projeter dans le futur
en gros on reconditionne on conditionne
on reprogramme le cerveau du sportif
pour qu'il puisse retrouver cette
réussite le gore le corps garde en cela
en mémoire il va pouvoir le refaire donc
information situation plus émotion égale
le cerveau va vouloir reproduire la
réussite peut-être pas au millimètre
auprès peut-être pas de la même manière
mais le corps le cerveau le système
nerveux vont vouloir retrouver cela
pour conclure j'ai envie de dire il y a
des choses importantes à mon sens
traiter les traumas
observer en tout cas jouer sur l'aspect
motivationnel notamment en donnant des
outils aux sportifs pour qu'ils
comprennent dans quel état il se situe
et ça peut être vraiment très simple
pareil prendre soin du mental prendre
soin de l'émotion chez le sportif pour
moi c'est ça l'équipe gagnante bien sûr
associer un travail physique tactique
nutritionnel le sommeil ça c'est aussi
important
et puis moi j'ai
Macron dans la vie et que le système
nerveux autonome on a beau tout donner
lors d'un match d'une compétition
d'ailleurs tout cela ça va permettre aux
sportif de mieux appréhender un combat
un match une compétition et bien moi
j'aime à croire que le système se régule
et se dérégule et en fait c'est son rôle
il est là pour ça
mais qu'en prendre note en prendre
conscience avec aussi de la douceur et
de l'écoute de soi dans le monde du
sport c'est peut-être pas plus mal
alors la prochaine fois que vous
entendez quelqu'un dire
le cerveau c'est sportif il a un cerveau
s'il vous plaît répondez-lui que sans le
corps la tête n'est rien que dans le
tout le cœur c'est beaucoup et que la
l'équipe gagnante pour moi c'est
d'allier le corps le cœur et l'esprit
merci
[Applaudissements]